awesome I'm really excited to be here so
Shaun reached out to me
last fall and tickle took us a little
bit to get this thing scheduled now that
I'm here one of the things that was sort
of holding us up as I was just starting
a new job so I started a new position at
the end of September and he reached out
about two weeks into that position and
we were trying to figure out like what
could I come talk about and the thing I
can come and talk about is building data
science in an org so from the
perspective of the first data science
hire in an org what does that even mean
what does that look like what kind of
decisions do you make what is your
day-to-day look like and so this talk is
just gonna be diving into that a little
bit I did put a call out on Twitter
actually to ask what kinds of things
people were interested in and I got like
five pages of responses and so clearly
this is the thing that people want to
talk about I'd love to talk to you folks
afterwards or online if you have
follow-up questions but this talk is
largely built around the questions that
came out of those conversations so
Clayton covered most of this my position
is lead data scientist at online med ed
I'm really passionate about getting
people into data science so co-organized
our ladies Austin and some other stuff
in Austin I would call myself a data
science generalist
have you guys heard of like the
generalist versus specialization thing
that's conversation that's happening
right now okay
so an article came out recently in HBR
and it was associated with stitch fix
and it was talking about this idea of
like a full-stack generalist versus
someone who specializes and when those
things are helpful when you have a big
team it's really helpful to have people
who specialize in certain parts of data
science like NLP or a machine learning
engineer or something like that I kind
of come at it from the opposite
direction so I've done a lot of
different data sciency things over the
past eight years or so and so I'm really
a generalist I'm comfortable working on
all of the parts of the stack but I'm
not necessarily super experienced at
every single part
I think that's a good skill to have if
you're going into startup data science
and I've recently made that transition
so a couple other things so and that's
the link to my blog at bianna Posie is
where you can find me on Twitter and
other things and then hashtag building
des is a hashtag I created when I
started this job to kind of track some
of the things that I was doing and so if
you go back you can see some real-time
tweets of what I was thinking at certain
times those making decisions that sort
of thing
okay so a little bit about online meded
my employer so they are a start-up
they've been around for about four years
or so they are a medical platform that
helps med students learn medicine better
so our mission is to make better doctors
and so they have hundreds of free videos
and you can log in you create an account
you can log in and watch those videos
and they help you do better on some of
your exams if you're a med student we
also the way that we make money is we
have add-ons and we have subscriptions
that you can pay for us there are things
like notes that you can buy and download
there's like a flashcard thing that you
can do and we're launching a mobile app
very very soon and so there's a ton of
data and ways that we can generate data
around our website and in fact they had
some data before they hired me so when
they decided they were at the point
where they wanted to hire someone they
had some data already that they'd been
collecting they had data over time but I
wouldn't say that they necessarily had
data about every part of the business
that they wanted to understand and so
they had some things that they were
interested in collecting but hadn't
collected yet but they also had piles of
data that they've collected but just
nobody had done anything with them so
they had data they had business
questions they had ideas of things that
they could do with the data but they
needed someone to step in and analyze it
one thing that's really cool about this
company in particular is my boss the CEO
is a trained epidemiologist so he is an
our guy he under
our he understands data he gets the
value of data science and that's been
really helpful for getting buy-in and
working on projects and all of that
stuff I'm happy to answer questions
about the company specifically so when I
walked in for my first day it's kind of
a green field right I actually had done
a little bit of consulting work for them
one project so I had a little bit of a
feel for what their data was like but
there was a lot of space where I could
kind of decide what I wanted to do what
projects to work on and that's a really
nice thing as a data scientist you can
decide the projects you want to work on
but it's also sort of scary because when
you walk in you don't know exactly like
what is the first thing that you should
be doing my directions from the CEO he
was about to go out on paternity leave
right when I started and so he gave me a
list of projects that he thought would
be helpful things that he wanted to know
and then he also mentioned in that list
just add value and so I like to think of
this as part of why I'm at the company
and so I'm really there to do analysis
to do cool things to add data to their
projects to help them become more data
informed and make better data-driven
decisions but I'm also like bottom line
there to just add value so when I see
things the data could help improve or
processes that I think we could work on
I have the flexibility to be able to
kind of step in and help but just been
really useful so I'm going to talk a lot
about data infrastructure and when I say
infrastructure I do mean all of the
things here but I have another slide to
show you the other side of
infrastructure that I mean so when you
walk into a company and they might have
data collection mechanisms it's how
they're getting their data how are they
capturing it so for us we were capturing
whether people watched videos for
example because you could mark that
you'd watched a video we also were
capturing individual things that you
could do on the site because there were
certain parts of the site that you had
to be a paid user in order to access and
so we have two gate access and so
there's some data there which was great
when you start working on problems
you'll quickly discover what the data
pipelines are if there are any data
pipelines so does the data go from the
mechanism into a sequel database or
something like that or is there a more
complicated process that's moving data
around or combining data from different
sources you start to sort of see that
right away and then the databases and
warehouses themselves what do those look
like are there many databases is there
one database has it changed a lot over
time are there core tables that you need
to care about you'll discover that very
quickly as well as any tools that they
have for doing exploratory data analysis
analysis in general or machine learning
tools and so that would probably be if a
company was a little bit more advanced
but I think this is all this stuff that
we think of when we think of
infrastructure when we talk about data
architecture there's a lot more that
goes into doing data science effectively
and efficiently though and so I'm
calling that foundational infrastructure
different people have different terms
for it
but one huge piece of that is
documentation and knowledge capture and
so making sure that the data you're
tracking like the lineage or tracking
any institutional knowledge that you
gained around that data this is actually
a really nice project when you're first
starting because you're learning a
company's data while you're learning
their business and their tech stack I
tend to take notes about anything that
I'm learning and so taking those notes
and turning them into documentation is a
logical next step and it helps me as
much as it helps the next person also
policies politics communications so if
you exist within an organization you
have to talk with other people you have
to communicate and politics can become a
part of that that doesn't necessarily
mean it's a bad thing it just means
figuring out sort of how you're going to
communicate with others also
establishing policies around your data
so if there are certain ways that you
want to treat certain pieces of data
maybe there's some data that everyone
should have access to maybe there are
some pieces of data that you don't
necessarily want to
for analysis starting to establish those
things on the team creating a plan to
deliver on goals so eventually you're
going to create goals or things that you
want to do and you need to have some
sort of plan of how you're going to get
from raw data to deliverables for the
company whatever those deliverables
might be so infrastructure isn't just
coming in and looking at the pipeline or
the sequel database and doing things
from there it's a lot more packaging
around it and then also as you start to
build a team thinking really carefully
about the structure and the roles on
that team so different teams look
differently depending on both the size
of the org that you're at as well as the
function of the team so in some
companies data is really the core
product those teams tend to look very
different than if you're working at
something like a start-up where they're
starting to add data or access the data
that they have and do analysis around it
so a little bit about what my first week
looks like this is not very data science
II but I think it's useful just to get
everyone on the same page like the first
week looks like the same week at a lot
of other jobs so learning the business
model is really important if you've seen
the data science Venn diagram knowing
the business is a big piece of that
getting access to all of the things that
you need access to database that takes
time that takes communication talking to
different stakeholders so my boss had me
meet with the two lead engineers in my
first week to kind of talk about where
things were if they had plans that might
work with the data we wanted to know
that starting to learn the data itself
and its lineage so I started to dive
into the databases a little bit just a
little bit of like select star from
limit 5 what does the state I'll even
look like what does it tie to or their
things I can tie together and starting
to get the stories like the oral history
of some of the data so when I came in my
boss said you know I'd love to hand you
a map but startup and so I really
learned that you know sometimes
as much as people would like to document
things and would like to have this
perfect documentation you know time gets
in the way and so getting comfortable
with that and talking and starting to
write things down as a way to add value
very quickly another thing that I ran
into was a little bit more cultural so I
was the first data scientists that
anyone in my company had worked with and
that was a really new position for me as
well I've done data science for a number
of years and a number of different orgs
but usually there was someone who was
sort of familiar with data science my
CEO was familiar with data science
because he sort of came from that world
like epidemiology statistics he got it
so I spent a lot of time my first week
just kind of explaining the things that
I did and some of the questions I got
were really basic even things like do
use get and so we really had to do a
little bit of education around the types
of things that we were doing with our
data currently the types of things that
we wanted to do with the data what the
road map was and just talking to people
and getting them on the same page with
what my role was what my tech stack was
it was interesting I got to know all of
the people who spoke Python very quickly
so yeah another thing that's really
important I think when you're starting
any new job but particularly if you're
building something if you're building
towards something I read this book the
first time d-day is based on a
recommendation on Twitter and so your
early wins have to be kind of double
wins like you want to be delivering
value as soon as you can for the company
but you also want to be laying out the
infrastructure and building things out
so that things are better in the long
run and so that was something that I
kept in my head a lot when I was working
on some of the early analyses so it's
been part of my time doing analysis and
then part of my time building towards
the future that's a really tricky
balance I would love to hear other
people talk about how they've done that
but yeah just being cognizant of the
fact that you want to be delivering
things while you're setting up for the
long term have you guys ever seen the
data science hierarchy of needs
this is familiar some of you okay cool I
love this this has been so useful for
explaining in my org what it is that I
do and why I care so much about
collecting data and having good data and
vetting it so at the very top of the
pyramid we have AI and deep learning
that's the stuff that they've all heard
about right below that a be testing
simple ml that kind of stuff that stuff
that we can get to pretty easily and
even if you walk into a startup that has
some data you might be able to get there
fairly quickly but I think it's really
important that the collect moves store
and explore transform all come at the
bottom of the pyramid like you really
need to have good data good data
collection in order to do all of the
cool stuff at the top of the pyramid and
so my first six months really have been
focused on the bottom of the pyramid
making sure that we have data we have
good data it's going to the right places
that sort of thing but yeah giving this
as a visual for folks to understand it's
been really helpful as I'm trying to
like build a case for building some of
this stuff so in the first few weeks I
built some core tooling and I have this
it's a no-brainer thing over here
because these are the things I would do
if I were to walk on to any team
these aren't decisions that I had to
make that were specific to being the
first data scientist or working at a
start-up these are just things that I
would do if they didn't exist in any
Orcs oh this is general advice one is
stack tools I'll show you in the next
slide what I mean by that but getting
things set up with like a git repository
setting up a slack channel just setting
up all the things that your team needs
to communicate and share work also
building a data dictionary and so shared
language of what your data means and
we'll cover all of this a little bit
more in depth a query library so
tracking all of your queries and get if
you're querying something often it's
probably very important probably
something you want to track and then
creating some sand block sand boxes to
connect to the data and start playing
with the data analyzing
the data and a little bit of templates
for building out projects so stack tools
and some things I added in the first few
weeks
this is confluence so we use the atlast
AK that's something I didn't make a
decision about it's a really common
stack but that confluence is like a
place where you can gather knowledge and
so it's kind of like wiki documents so
we have our data science space and we
have some pages and stuff that I've
added there we added a JIRA board and so
we could talk we could do a whole
separate talk about running agile on
data science and whether that's a good
idea or not a good idea I have some
opinions but I'm still tracking the work
that I'm doing in tickets so we created
a JIRA board so that we could start
tracking the work a data science channel
on our slack internal slack group
channel and so this was partially so
that we could answer questions from
other people in the org and then
partially so that I could disseminate
any of the things that I've done and
then finally we use bitbucket instead of
github but repositories so creating
places where we could put and store our
code and give everyone access so these
are just kind of the basic tools that I
think you would need to set up a team
I'm sure there are more things that you
could add to this list but this is what
I did in the first few days first week
that I was on the next thing that I
worked on is building a data dictionary
so as I was talking with people from
different teams about the types of data
that they had what data pain points
there were there are fields or tables
that they were using over and over again
I was recording all of that I think
that's really important it's really
helpful for yourself so you're setting
yourself up to answer questions in the
future but also for the next person so
the next person who started working with
the data I gave her a data dictionary
and so she has the things that I have
explored my knowledge of those things
I have worked at places where the
history of the data is entirely oral
that's a really bad thing that's not a
thing that you want to start with and so
I think when you're learning is the best
time to really be building these things
the other thing that's kind of cool
about a data dictionary is like it
tracks my knowledge of the data as I'm
building it and we'll see the same thing
with a query repository but you can see
me learning the databases and the data
better by like the updates in the data
dictionary and query libraries which is
kind of cool because your analysis is
only as good as your knowledge of the
data and that really is going to inform
the conclusions that you make so when I
say a query repository or oh you have a
question yeah so nothing that was built
to make data dictionaries mine's just in
Google sheets and so we have a shared
Google sheet and we have the Lincoln
that we put the link on our confluence
eventually it should have a better home
but for now start up and we're still
building it so yeah good question and
also different people have different
opinions on that this is actually that's
a question I asked on Twitter and I got
a lot of really interesting varied
responses that would be a good thread
for me to probably go dig up but if you
search for it I'm sure you could find it
people have strong opinions on the tools
that you should use to do that and where
it should live some people think it
should live within your like sequel
queries or within your code I opted to
keep it separately and that's just
worked for me on other teams but you
could really go either way yeah those
are small decisions to make depending on
that work so the query library is just
the idea of taking your sequel putting
it in a place where other people can see
it and then tracking it with git so if
you're changing your sequel over time
for me for example I'm finding out more
about our user base a lot of this stuff
that involves is like filters like as
you figure out like oh this field made
sense at this time but then this thing
happened in our software and it changed
and so maybe don't use it after this
time if you start to look at someone's
sequel queries over time you'll see that
sort of change and this is really nice
because you can document like why you're
making those changes and what the
knowledge was that caused you to update
those queries and you're always going to
need that query again that's my other
thing whenever I do like a one-off
project someone always asks for a
different version of it or an update of
it and so it's really nice to just save
the sequel one place and have access to
it another thing that I've done is
sandbox projects with notebooks how many
of you have ever heard of project
template before it's an hour package or
cookie cutter for Python okay yeah so
it's the idea of creating a template for
your projects and it just makes your
life a lot easier you don't have to
think about the architecture the
scaffolding you just kind of copy this
pre-existing thing and then you start to
fill it in with like your notebook and
your data and all that good stuff so
this is the outline that comes with
project template I didn't actually use
that this time around I learned by using
project template I've edited a little
bit but I think they're a good starting
point and then the other thing is like a
sandbox notebook and so I couldn't
actually paste our notebooks here but I
kind of pasted the idea of what they do
importing a bunch of commonly used
packages connecting to the database I
put like a sample query in there and
then taking that query and turning it
into a data frame and so that's just a
really nice thing because then I can
edit it and I get started and I just
don't think about the scaffolding
anything that saves me time and that I'm
doing over and over again I try to
automate and earlier the better so that
was the first week two weeks or so
so the first six months really like what
I've been doing up until now a lot of it
has been tooling decisions and making
decisions about the business in this
talk I'm not really going into much on
the analysis that I was doing but I was
balancing this the whole time with
delivery
and answering business questions so
that's kind of the piece that's missing
from this picture so one of the
questions that we had was like how can
we help with business intelligence we
wanted to make some bi sort of decisions
and bi bi I mean in this case I guess
like data that was looking backwards at
what happened and so we have
stakeholders who want to be able to
answer really basic questions things
like how many people used our software
in the last month and we didn't have
anyone doing that and so I built some
really basic reporting and stuff to do
that are we collecting enough data so we
knew that there were holes in our
customer acquisition flow in our usage
that we wanted to try to plug and so we
had to figure out the best way to
collect more data sharing our analyses
so originally when I started doing
analyses I would put them in a report
and then I put that report on confluence
because that's where we wanted
everything to live and one liked central
location but pretty quickly I realized
that's not reproducible that's not best
practice I was going in and just
updating the numbers on the report like
once a month and so we decided that we
needed a tool to be able to share these
things and to be able to help other
people like run them live that would be
helpful and so we started looking into
different ways that we could share
analysis a lot of these are problems
that I've encountered at other companies
but usually at the point at which
someone has figured it out and so the
thing that was most interesting to me is
like the decision-making process around
this like I know I need reproducible or
reporting but what do I actually do to
get there helping other departments so
we know there are departments who are
not data-driven who haven't seen the
data that goes along with their work and
so we wanted to be able to provide that
data and help them make good decisions
shaping data pipelines so I think this
is actually a good project to do at a
time where you've been working with the
data a little bit not right off the bat
because you know the data better you
start to know some of the quirks you
start to know some of the things that
you might
look out for and so I've recently
started thinking about data pipelines
and what those should look like and then
what other resources do we need so as
we're going along or realizing there's
other resources that we need what are
those things how do we get them so we'll
walk through some of these decisions
this first one was around powering
business intelligence I don't know if
you've all seen this before it's a tool
called chart mogul and so one of the
things I had to do is the first data
person in the org was connect the data
to all of these different apps and
things that would help the business so
this is a bi tool this cohort analysis
is actually kind of cool it looks into
the way that people turn over time but
powering this thing actually took some
time and some thoughts so we have
changed our billing system twice and so
those migrations mean that we have data
lives in different formats and different
systems from different times and so
that's something that I had to think
about how do we combine those things and
actually we have an engineer who does a
lot of customer support stuff and so she
had a really good understanding of the
data and the billing systems in
particular and so she was particularly
well suited to help with this project
and connecting accounts across systems
and that sort of thing that's not a
really that's an example of something
that's not super exciting it's not an
exciting or new problem to solve but
it's the kind of thing that needs to get
solved and preferably the earlier the
better so that those things aren't pain
points later on down the road
another thing we had to focus on was
data collection and so my friend is an
analytics architect I didn't know that
there was a term for that role but what
she does is worry about eventing data
and figuring out what that data should
look like and how it should interact
with different systems and so I've spent
probably four months working on our data
architecture and our data collection
that's really like that's the bottom
part of the pyramid it's super
foundational
super important and so we settled on a
tool called segments that decision was
made before I came on board but it's
been good so far and we used that in
order to collect data on our website so
for example if you do a search
we weren't capturing like what folks
were searching for there's business
value in that we could start to do
predictive things around search we could
start to upsell and cross-sell there's
all kinds of good business things we
could do there so one of the things that
we had to do was come up with the kinds
of events that we would want to track
how exactly we would want to track them
where we want that data to live how does
that data combine and someone has to be
sort of in charge of all of that and so
that's been a huge part of my role is
personally coming up with like over 200
events that we're now tracking on our
website and then working with our devs
to implement the tech that we need in
order to track those things q aying that
data which is super important so the
things that I'm asking for from our devs
are not always exactly the things that I
get back things get lost in translation
and communication and so it's not just
coming up with the plan it's also
working through the data and making sure
that it's actually the thing that we
think it is and that it's doing the
things that we think it is the other
kind of cool thing about segments is
that we use it to power some of our
other data outputs and so we've
collected that and Amazon redshift
it feeds Google Analytics we're able to
connect it with HubSpot which is a
marketing tool talk about that in a
second and then we're able to connect
that with mode analytics which we're
using to do analytics and dashboards so
I'm sharing analyses internally this is
where we're using a tool called mode
analytics there's all kinds of stuff
that you can use to do this you can also
choose to like spin up your own way of
sharing reports so this decision took a
lot of input from outside sources I
talked to friends I asked questions on
Twitter and eventually we decided to
give this a try partially because of our
particular needs so our data lives in
multiple databases and it was
surprisingly hard to find a tool
lets you combine data from multiple
databases and then let business users
kind of access that data that's one of
those pain points that's very particular
to our organization but when you start
looking at tools those are the kinds of
things that you have to think through so
we're able to share analyses internally
here and it allows you to build like
Python notebooks and our notebooks so
you can do an actual analysis it's not
just like select star from and then
bubble up that report which has been
really nice another thing that we've
done is enabled marketing with data and
so this is HubSpot those modalities are
things that people can do on our website
like you could download a whiteboard
it's like an image of after a lecture
all of the notes on a whiteboard those
are things that we're collecting with
segments and so those are things we had
to specifically decide that we wanted to
collect decide that we want to analyze
down the line invest in that value and
then pull that in as the only data
person making sure that the right data
goes to the right person in the right
way that has fallen to me and so this is
an example of the kind of project that
I'm doing if I'm helping to enable other
stakeholders and it's all this sort of
foundational work that'll let us get
even more data and have even more things
that we can start to analyze which is
really exciting
shaping data pipelines so focusing on
pain points we figured out that in order
to see purchases at a certain time we
have to query and go through kind of
snake through something like eight
different sequel tables those things
just weren't designed by a data
scientist or someone with the end data
or the end use of data science in mind
and so having someone like me go back
through them and kind of figure out like
ok where could we pull this data how
could we pull this data together in a
better way in our own pipeline where we
could build our own sort of curated
version of the truth that makes sense
for doing analysis raw data is artifacts
it doesn't necessarily represent the
truth it represents the truth at the
time at which you pulled it and in the
way in which
you pulled it and so sometimes you have
to kind of navigate what that truth
might be and pull the data into a
different format to make it work for you
or to make it work for the team the
third piece is automating where it makes
sense so as I've been finding pain
points like oh hey I pulled this same
query once a week at least that tells me
that that should be its own view or its
own table I should be doing that roll-up
once so that I don't have to keep doing
it
so the analyses that you're doing can
start to inform the architecture and the
data engineering decisions that you make
another really important part is
knowledge documentation so these are
actual tables that we have in our
confluence that help to explain
different parts of the business and it's
mostly the stuff that you like have to
go look up you're like oh what was that
code again what did that mean or what
was this group of people and so I would
advocate for taking anything that you
constantly have to look up or try to
keep in your head and just writing that
down putting it in a central location
letting everyone see it and edit it and
touch it and then you get the shared
benefit of the knowledge across the
institution so for example we have
different subscription codes and so we
created this thing that explains all of
the different subscriptions and and what
they mean from a business perspective
another thing that's been really useful
here and at other companies is like a
calendar of notable events so sometimes
you'll be looking at data over time and
you'll see like a weird spike or a weird
dip or something that's unexpected and
when you've talked to a business
stakeholder you might develop a whole
analysis and then talk to a business
stakeholder and they'll know something
like oh yeah that's when we switched
billing systems or that's when we
launched that new product or that's when
so-and-so started working on this other
stack and so those kinds of things are
so helpful to know in hindsight when
you're looking at the data but they're
not the kinds of things that people
think to write down especially if they
don't come from a data background so
we've created a calendar of those kinds
of events and you can see some of the
questions that we're answering and then
also promotion
codes overview so we have like
promotions that we offer in our store if
we're doing cohort analysis some of the
people who buy on a promotion might look
different than customers who don't buy
on a promotion and so knowing that data
and understanding it having some having
it summarized in an easy way just makes
us get from raw data to insight that
much faster so the data science
hierarchy of needs if we come back here
and this is really where I've spent my
first six months so a lot of collecting
the data a lot of moving it around a
little bit figuring out storage figuring
out what our events should look like and
designing that stuff this is all stuff
that is investment right so we're
spending a little bit of time now in
hopes that it will pay off in the long
run having a really solid data
infrastructure is something that we'll
be able to optimize both for our team as
well as to leverage on other teams
so as we're finding pain points and
creating new resources to tackle them
we're creating things that are useful
for other people a good example of that
is like switching billing systems in
order to find all of the people who have
ever made a purchase for example that
means that you have to go to different
billing systems and so one of the things
that we've created recently is just a
single table with all of that
information sounds so simple but if you
don't have that you're constantly just
redoing this work and rethinking through
things and it's just clogging up the
amount of time that it takes to get from
data to actual insight so the next six
months and will be spent just a little
bit further up the pyramid so the
collect stage is nearly done moving and
storage is kind of the next thing that
I'm going to be really working on
alongside some analysis so we're
actually going to get to some cool
analysis in the next six months that I'm
really excited about
so this role has been a little bit
different than like a traditional data
scientist role because you're making
some of these decisions that are
foundational and you're setting up both
yourselves and
people to be able to use the data in a
way that's effective that's been really
cool and interesting for me especially
as someone who has opinions about this
stuff having seen some of the way that
people work with data been cluttered by
poor ecosystems this is a problem I've
been really excited to work on but I
feel like it's really important to be
honest that if you get hired as the
first data scientist in a company you're
not starting out doing AI unless someone
has curated a really beautiful path to
get there for you so sometimes I sort of
feel like I'm the person riding out in
front of the army to see what everything
looks like and sort of come up with a
plan and have an idea before we actually
get people and invest time and resources
into all of that stuff so some upcoming
projects for me building stronger data
pipelines so an engineer once told me
that startups run on cron jobs and duct
tape and I love that it took me a while
to kind of wrap my head around the idea
of that being okay because I came from
larger companies where that's not
something that they would encourage but
yeah for now we're crown jobs and duct
tape and we'll get to a point where
we'll need to have something that's a
little bit less brittle and so I'm
excited to work on that a little bit
alongside the analysis also enabling
stakeholders with data so we have a ton
of different ways like all of this new
data that we've been collecting with
that tool segment those two hundred-plus
events that stated that's never been
seen in our company before there's all
kinds of value there that's completely
untapped so I'm really excited to share
that and do more analysis on all of this
stuff I got a few questions about like
first data science projects and what to
pick in my case my CEO understands data
he had some questions that he knew were
the types of questions that I could
answer but I think general advice is
like to talk to stakeholders figure out
what's working and what's not and if
there are pain points if there are
things that they kind of wish they could
see and where data could be the most
helpful
I've actually been having those
conversations last week this week and
next week and so these are the questions
that I'm asking my stake holder so if
you want to steal these you completely
can but I'm asking basically like what
data do you wish you had like in a dream
world
what would you be collecting and the
sooner I know these things the sooner we
can set up for them so even if we're not
collecting it now in six months we might
have enough data to make some really
cool decisions and do some interesting
analysis what data you use currently and
where does it live I'm just interested
in this from a data perspective so if
folks are grabbing data from a source
that you didn't know about or maybe a
source that isn't as up-to-date as
another source it's really helpful to
have an idea of how data flows around
your organization and I don't mean in
pipelines I mean like where do people go
when they have these kinds of questions
and then my last question for the
stakeholders is like do you have any
questions about data and online meded
and that's been really interesting there
are people who have had like legitimate
questions about things that we're
tracking or where do things live or how
do I access and so it's been nice to get
some of those pain points out of the way
so that we can help like democratize our
data and get more and be able to provide
more the other things so like build
versus buy and vendor decisions is
something that I've been asked about I
think this is really tough it's really
org tie org and decision by decision but
this is the way that I think through it
so I think the most important thing you
can do is develop a really thorough
understanding of the pain points of your
organization and how you might fix them
then go ahead and survey the landscape
see what kinds of solutions are out
there talk to your developers to if
you're thinking about building something
in-house like what would that look like
what's the effort I've been surprised
sometimes at how easy or hard things
would be to track if we're interested in
tracking them build versus buy so
talking to people has been really
helpful and then asking for advice so I
specifically asked the community when I
have questions but just asking for
advice generally has been really good
and then weighing out the pros and cons
of short term versus long
term solutions so you might notice that
we didn't go with tableau as our bi tool
I've worked in organizations where
tableau has been really great it's been
really helpful we don't need all of
those bells and whistles right now it's
just not where we are and so just being
realistic about the pros and cons and
short term long term where are you now
where do you want to grow it's been
helpful question yeah it should be yeah
exactly totally yes of course but it's a
big consideration so like for us you
know we're a start-up we have to make
tough decisions and we have to run in a
way that's a little bit agile and a
little bit like edge of the map and so
that can be a really cool thing it can
empower you to look at new tools or
solutions that other people haven't
tried but it also can mean sometimes
that things can be cost prohibitive some
of the common tools and then finally
make a decision and you can always go
back if your decision doesn't work out
you know but just getting something in
place and then another question I've
been asked a lot about is being the only
person who is doing the thing that
you're doing in an org and like what do
you do and the thing that I do the most
is lean on community so and the
community has been really helpful for
answering questions that I have I shared
this slide because when I was trying to
figure out like okay how do other people
distribute or host reports and
dashboards like I have some ideas I've
done it in other companies but like
maybe there's something out there I'm
totally not considering and you can see
I got 51 responses so people are really
interested in sharing their knowledge
and sharing the things that they've
learned and taking some of that advice
to heart can be really helpful and you
can also keep you engaged with other
people so it's nice to have an idea of
what other people are doing and then you
can take those best practices in-house
as well as have a sounding board so you
don't feel lonely or like you're really
the only person doing this stuff there
are lots of people who are the only data
scientists or the first data scientists
are a new data scientist or a very
uriens data scientists wherever you
might be
[Applause]